it's ladies night for my brain dump
america's kilometers overnight exit from
afghanistan was a disgraceful disaster
that bruce presidents biden's reputation
forever on the world stage it was a
spineless surrender that made the us
look weak cowardly and chaotic it's no
exaggeration to say that it may have
emboldened vladimir putin to invade
ukraine sensing that the world's number
one superpower may have lost its stomach
for a fight and most shamefully for a
president who regularly boasts about
being a women's rights champion there's
been no greater victim in this travesty
than the millions of women of
afghanistan in one fell capitulating
swoop they were catapulted back to the
medieval dark ages of taliban rule these
militant misogynists have kicked girls
out of schools and banned women from
most jobs they've forbidden them from
playing sports they've banned women from
going to public parks on the same day as
men or making long journeys without male
chaperone it's been an ever escalating
program of gender apartheid and many of
the truly courageous and inspiring women
who dare protest have been either locked
up or just disappeared
now a taliban has decided that all women
must wear a full head-to-toe burqa and
their male relatives and employers have
been made the enforcers if women show
their faces their male guardian gets
fined jailed or fired from his job
all this from his supposedly new and
inclusive taliban which some people
farcically branded taliban 2.0
after seizing back power last summer
they vowed to treat women more fairly
they lied i don't ever want again to
hear president biden boast about his
support for women's rights after the way
he betrayed afghanistan's women but i do
want to hold the taliban to account for
their treatment of women and i'll do
that tonight live when i speak directly
to their official spokesman
well nothing will make the taliban froth
of the mouth more than the fact that for
70 years britain's had a female monarch
queen elizabeth is there sort of
ultimate nightmare a strong independent
well-educated woman more than the equal
of any man she ever meets but these are
worrying times for her majesty now 96
and increasingly poor health her most
important constitutional duty is to open
parliament each year and give the queen
speech which formally sets out what a
government plans to do
but today she missed it for the first
time in 59 years
and the sight of her eldest son prince
charles reading the queen's speech for
her as he faked an occasional emotional
glance at her crown placed pointedly
nearby was a massively significant
moment in british history
to put all this into challenging times
her majesty's government will play a
leading role
in defending democracy
and freedom
across the world
including continuing to support the
people of ukraine
well to put all this into perspective
the last time an heir to the throne
delivered a state opening a parliament
queen victoria was still a toddler
but today was so much more than just a
constitutional collector's item no one
wants to talk about this but the
monarchy and with it britain is now
hurtling towards a momentous transition
so much about what it is to be british
has been defined by the constant stoic
stately presence of one woman so much
about the queen has defined what it
means to be british we're gonna have to
re-learn what that means and discover
whether the monarchy under charles and
then his own eldest son william can even
survive let alone thrive
the taliban will doubtless be thrilled
that our next two monarchs will be men
but we will all miss this magnificent
woman more than they could ever
understand and more than many of us may
currently realize
america has never had a female president
but according to president biden's
sister valerie the cavalry may soon be
arriving unfortunately it's not the kind
of cavalry that any of us want to see
coming over the hill it's our old friend
meghan markle
we embrace
all women and we welcome her to come in
and
join the democratic party so you think
she'll make a good potential
candidate one day maybe for president
yes perhaps of course she will
what
is that a joke
that's there is somebody out there less
suited to become a leader of the free
world but i can't currently think of one
and before you think this is some kind
of joke remember that meghan markle's
old friends probably thought the same
thing when she told him she's going to
hook her claws into a british prince and
make herself stupendously rich and
famous i wouldn't put anything past this
scheming princess pinocchio probably
sees the white house as a perfectly
feasible next rung on her relentless
climb up the social ladder megan's
already been exposed for inappropriately
phoning up bemused american politicians
to harangue and i'm sure she's looked at
donald trump's success in 2016 and
thought herself
tv star
zero political influence experience
craves money
deeply polarizing
massive narcissist
and not currently talking to piers
morgan she also needs a new career let's
face it a current one as a professional
two-faced exploiter of royal titles
isn't going so well her children's book
bombed
her spotify podcasts have barely been
heard
netflix just cancelled her animated
series
and the queens banned her and hypocrite
harry from the buckingham palace balcony
at the platinum jubilee
[Music]
yeah
megan's doing the maths and already
planning the world's wokest inauguration
speech just don't say i didn't warn you
and for a woman who wouldn't inspire me
to open a jar of cookies and i love
cookies to one who's genuinely inspired
millions of people in some of their very
darkest moments
deborah hi i'm deborah james also known
as bell babe two and a half years ago at
the age of 35 i was diagnosed with stage
four bowel cancer it was at that moment
that my entire world changed and they
found a six and a half centimeter tumor
in my
bowel
debra james is an extraordinary human
being she's battled stage four bowel
cancer for five years and during that
time she's hosted a podcast called you
me in the big c and a column in the sun
in which she communicates about her
struggle with astonishing candor clarity
and humility she doesn't put any punches
it's sharp it's witty it's sometimes
heartbreaking commentary on the kind of
things people don't like to talk about
what cancer does to your body your
children your mental health today should
reveal a typical frankness that a body
just can't cope any longer she's under
hospice care at home with her family
waiting for the end of a remarkable life
the response to that heart-rending
announcement has been quite staggering
she just asked supporters to buy her a
glass of wine to see her out and in 24
hours she's raised more than 1.7 million
pounds for her bowel babe fund
on a day when inspirational women are in
sharp focus there aren't many more
deserving of our respect and affection
than deborah james and on behalf of
everybody she's helped normal life she's
almost certainly say through her
informative educational homilies i
simply want to say this
thank you deborah
you